gamer schminken haben glatte haut und
sind sozial völlig unfähig wochen das
ganz anders um das sind alles vorteile
ergebnis natürlich auch wie spielt aber
für die meisten zocker gilt wie bin
gesund und zwar besonders und dafür
legen jedenfalls wissenschaftliche
studien jetzt in science fiction von der
gamescom zu kommen
mehr als 300.000 gaming fans werden
wieder die gamescom bevölkerung was
auffällt sie sehen erfreulich gesund
aus und dafür gibt es eben einen
einfachen grund
gaming ist gesund aber erstmals eine
offizielle entwarnung der gewalt spiel
gespielt wird nicht krank oder
entwickelt sich irgendwie abnormal ein
amerikanischer forschungsteam hat
letztes jahr mit einer sehr großen
anzahl von kindern nämlich und zurück
zu den 1000 untersucht ob es
verhaltensstörungen bei ihnen oder
vermehrt depressionen gibt die gewalt
spiele zocken er ergebnis es gibt keine
signifikanten unterschiede zu kindern
wie zb eher harmlose spiele spielen also
schädlich sind games immer nicht aber
sie sind eben sogar fünf beispiel ein
super mario 64
hier untersuchte das max-planck-institut
die gehirnentwicklung während einer
zweimonatigen phase bei den
teilnehmenden erwachsenen die ja
eigentlich schon ein aufwendiges gehirn
haben müssen
rufen sie hirnregionen die für das
gaming benutzt wurden und dass innerhalb
von zwei monaten erfahren regionen die
für die navigation im dreidimensionalen
raum erinnerungen strategisches plan und
feinmotorische fähigkeiten befasst
waren
denn dieser könne weiß wie bei besser
sehen durch ego shooter wie mcmaster
university in kanada wie erwachsene die
nach der erkrankung mit dem grauen stadt
trotz operation nicht mehr so sehen
konnten medal of honor zocken ergebnis
nach 40 stunden spielzeit in vier wochen
berichteten die versuch teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer deutlich besser sehen zu
können
beispiel 3 besser sehen für alle auch
generell verbessert dass vielen von ego
shootern klassen bavariae von der
university of rochester in den usa und
ihr team wiesen 2009 verschiedene
gruppen mit testversuchen jeweils 50
stunden an return am 14
call of duty 2 und sie sind diejenigen
die super soften verbesserten hiervon
57 hintergrund die eu sicherstellen
extrem hohe anforderungen an das auge
und das hören da ständig der gesamte
bildschirm auf veränderung und bewegung
hin aberkannt werden muss
das schulter sehen offenbar und führt
zu den deutlich verbesserten
fähigkeiten bei den personen die die
sind zwei gespielten partie übrigens
mit beispiel wir sie hoben sollen mehr
zocken ein forschungsteam vom beth
israel medical center in new york
untersuchte die fähigkeiten konnte
rogan und zerrungen und franz warten
werde heraus klinik nämlich wie in
ihrem eifer games krisen operiert ist in
über 20 prozent schneller und machten
bis zu 37 prozent weniger fehler im
western beispiel fünf was haben ex
fußballer philipp lahm kabarettist
eckart von hirschhausen und der frühere
aok chef jürgen graalmann gemeinsam sie
haben in einen games publisher für
senioren investiert retro brain als die
firma und sie entwickelt viele für
senioren und seniorinnen aber nicht dass
ich einfach nur so sondern bei dem jede
gegründet werden jetzt einige beispiele
die firma hat spiele entwickelt die die
entwicklung der demenz deutlich
verlangsamen sollen und vor allem auch
die motorischen fähigkeiten fördern
durch werden stürzen verhindert und die
seniorinnen und senioren sollen länger
selbstständig bleiben zurzeit werden
die rentner games von der berliner
humboldt universität untersucht ich bin
mal gespannt und halten euch natürlich
dazu auf dem laufenden wenn ihr zu
diesem und zu anderen geben kann wieder
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht
gehen
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit big bang urknall aufgedeckt wie
immer extrem spannend wachstum und
ansonsten getan
dapd